Narrator: From AirPods filled with earwax
to algae-covered pools
and air vents filled with dust,
we followed the professionals
to uncover the satisfying ins and outs
of how some of the filthiest things
are professionally deep cleaned.
Our first expert is Julius
from Phone Fix Craft.
He shows us how dirty our phones can get
and how he makes them look brand new.
Can you hear that?
Julius now shares how to bring
clogged AirPods back to life.
When was the last time that
you went to the dentist?
Dental hygienist Faye Donald
proves that teeth cleanings
are nothing to be afraid of.
Today, I'm going to show you
how guided biofilm therapy, or GBT,
works when we professionally clean
a patient's mouth from start to finish.
My job as a dental hygienist
is to detect and treat
but most importantly
prevent periodontal disease.
Biofilms are highly organized
microscopic communities of bacteria.
But it's responsible for bleeding gums,
for bad breath, for
some dental infections,
for some of the unsightly deposits
that we see on our teeth,
and, of course, it's linked to
some more serious,
systemic diseases, as well.
So, here we can see plaque
and calculus deposits,
but more concerning is
the color of the gums,
which are red, and they're
also puffy and swollen,
and that would lead us to
believe either gingivitis
or even periodontal disease
could be present here.
One of the problems with biofilm
is that you can't see it
and you can't feel it,
so I use a dye called Biofilm Discloser,
which is an organic, colored dye.
So, when the dye's applied to the teeth,
which have biofilm on them,
it changes the color of the biofilm.
And it's a really clever two-tone dye,
so it means that it stains early biofilm,
which is less than three days old, pink,
and it stains mature biofilm,
which is more than three days old, blue.
The patient is shown in the mirror
the stained biofilm.
Biofilms are microscopic,
whereas the plaque is a
biofilm that's matured,
and it's large enough to
be seen with the naked eye.
Ideally, what we want is
to disrupt dental biofilm
before it has the chance
to mature into plaque.
So, this is where we start
the cleaning process,
and it is completely different
to the old-fashioned methods
of curettage and hand scaling.
So, here I'm using a
tool called Airflow Max,
which acts like a warm jet
wash for inside the mouth.
It uses a combination of warm water
and tiny soluble and antimicrobial powder.
Airflow Max will remove
100% of the biofilm from the teeth
and all of the surrounding tissues,
including underneath the gums,
where it's dark and warm
and the biofilm really likes to hide.
I'm also using the Airflow Max
not just to take the biofilm away,
but it takes the stains away, as well,
so the mouth looks and feels
super clean afterwards.
It's very comfortable for the patient.
It's gentle, it's
efficient, it's very safe,
with no abrasion or damage
to the tooth surface at all.
After we've disrupted all of the biofilm
and we've removed all of the stains,
Piezon No-Pain is used
at this stage,
and it uses ultrasonic vibrations
to remove any remaining hard calculus.
It shaves the calculus off very gently.
So it's very different
to the old-fashioned methods
of scraping the teeth,
which would take calculus away
but would also scratch
the tooth's surface.
Stage seven of the GBT process is
our quality-control stage, really.
So, here, I would spend a few moments
checking around the whole mouth
to ensure that all the
deposits have been removed
and all the biofilm's been disrupted.
So, at this stage, I would hand the mirror
back to my patient
so they can see the
before-and-after results
of their guided-biofilm-therapy treatment.
I usually ask my patients
to run their tongue over
their teeth at this stage
to feel how silky-smooth they are
now that the biofilm and calculus is gone.
Learning good oral-hygiene habits
is like learning to swim.
You have to be shown, so
ask a dental hygienist
to teach you how to clean
your teeth properly.
Spend the most time and
concentrate the most efforts
on the areas that you can't see.
That's where you'll find the most biofilm.
So in between the back teeth,
underneath the gumline,
around the base of restorations.
Ah! I love my job!
I love it so much,
because I get to put smiles
on people's faces every single day.
What other job in the
world gets to do that?
Next, Miles Laflin transforms
this murky green pool
back into clean, clear waters.
Hi, I'm Miles,
and I'm going to show you
how I professionally clean a pool
from start to finish.
[water bubbling]
This pool's not looking too good.
I'm gonna get the submersible
pump out straight away,
pump the water out,
and then come back the next day.
So, here we are, the next day.
It's empty, but there's a blanket of algae
all over the pool.
I'm gonna shovel it all
up, put it in buckets.
Basically, the green sludge is,
after a pool's been left for a long time
without any chlorine or
any sanitizer in the pool,
you'll get algae buildup.
Most of them don't smell that bad,
but when the sludge is
really thick on the bottom
and you disturb it,
this obviously has not been
disturbed for a long time,
the smell that comes out is crazy.
Basically, when we had the pool empty,
we realized how many frogs there were.
I'd never seen so many frogs
in a pool before in my life.
Like, every scoop, every shovelful,
there was maybe one or two frogs on it.
So we had to get them out,
put them on the side of the pool,
and let them run off into the bushes.
So, we used hydrochloric
acid mixed with water,
so it was diluted down.
Get out the old Karcher K4.
Start pressure washing the pool down.
It's all coming up pretty well.
At the bottom of the pool
there's a main drain.
There'd been some work
done around the pool,
like the slabbing and that.
Obviously there's a lot of
leaves gone into the pool,
so a lot of muck at the bottom.
And just built up and solidified.
So that had to be broken up.
Nothing special, it was just, like,
an old screwdriver from the van.
That helped to get into it,
break it up, and then hoover it out.
[vacuum sucking]
The dirtiest parts on the pool
are going to be the filters.
'Cause basically they have,
the water runs through the filters
continuously or on a timer.
Blue tank is the fill arm with sand in.
And that keeps the pool water clean.
What it does is catches all the dirt
and the stuff that's
floating around in the pool.
And then once a week,
once every two weeks,
whenever I come do a maintenance,
do a backwash, and that
gets rid of all the dirt
and anything that's been
floating around in the pool.
New sand in, cut it open.
I'll do five bags of sand
so there's 24-inch fill-up.
Slip the lid back on.
[water gurgling]
When I do the chemicals,
they all look the same, chlorine as well.
It's all just like sort of white powder.
But basically I'm just
balancing the chemicals
on the swimming pools when
I'm doing the maintenance.
A few bags of salt needed.
Three 25-kilo bags.
[water bubbling]
Basically, what happens
when you pour it in,
it goes through the system
and runs through a salt cell,
which is just a chlorine generator.
So as it's running through the salt cell,
it uses a process called electrolysis.
I think I said it right.
Basically just turning
into chlorine for the pool.
Get a brush out, brush it all around
so it's not just sitting on the floor,
and that's that job done.
This was definitely the
worst pool I've worked on
in terms of how dirty it was
and how much algae there was.
And smell. The smell was just ridiculous.
It was unbearable at some times.
It didn't take me all day,
it didn't take too long.
I know it looks like a lot of mess,
but it went pretty well.
A lot of people say to me, you know,
"Don't you ever just feel like
just jumping in the pool?"
I mean, on a really hot day I do.
But other than that,
I'm not really that bothered about it.
Miles now revives a hot tub
that is perfect for a spa day.
Today I'm going to show you
how to professionally clean a hot tub.
All right, this is probably
the worst hot tub I've had to work on.
There's literally slugs, spiders,
the water's black,
and the smell is just disgusting.
So, the first thing I've
done when I got there
was taking the cover
off for the actual job,
which, you had to take the cover off,
inspect it, see how bad it was.
We took that off and
stood it up on the grass,
and that got jet washed and brushed down.
And there's a lot of creases in the cover,
so there's slugs in there as well,
still trying to hide and
sort of stay in their home,
but they all got cleared out.
So it was mostly water with the jet wash,
and then you had a little
bit of cleaning solution.
With the cover, that took
around an hour to clean.
On the side there's a
lot of black markings,
like slime and dirt,
and it's still a lot slugs
sort of slithering around.
Like, 100 slugs on this hot tub.
And, yeah, the guy said
he hadn't used it for, like, 10 years.
So I just started off with a jet wash,
and they sort of got jet
washed away at first.
There was so many, and
to be honest with you,
I don't really fancy picking up slugs, so.
So, the white tube there,
that's connected to my submersible pump,
which I'm using to pump water
from the hot tub down the drain.
So I've got the broom
out, 'cause you've got,
where you sit down in
the hot tub is quite,
it's a bit like a bowl, so
it'll hold a lot of water,
and what I'm just doing is
I'm just pushing it into the middle
so the submersible pump
can drain it out easier.
At the bottom of the tub,
you just had a little bit
of dirty water and a little bit of grit.
So, underneath here,
you've got the main circulating pump.
You've got the heater for the hot tub.
All the pump equipment's
kept underneath the hot tub.
So, I pulled the panel back,
which all needed to be
cleaned out as well,
and I used the Hoover to get all of that.
So, a hot-tub flush is a chemical,
which you will pour in through
where the filters are usually set,
and then you turn on all
the jets in the hot tub.
So, yeah, once you put
the hot-tub flush in
and it starts reacting with all the fats
and anything that's
caught up in the tubes,
inside the hot tub, it creates a foam,
and then you can also see, in the foam,
you can see the dirt
which is coming out of the pipes as well.
So you can see it's working.
Once it bubbles up, you can get in there
and just net them out so they don't --
'cause what happens is it'll
start sticking to the sides,
'cause it's like an acrylic material.
So it will stick to the sides,
and if you don't scoop it out,
you'll have to then scrub the sides again.
So it's just easier just to get in there,
net now the foamy bits and
all of the dirt on the foam,
and it'll make it easier for yourself.
So, I've got this hot-tub filter here,
and it's looking really black.
There's a lot of dirt all over it,
and I'm going to give it a rinse down
just to clear it so it's
filtering properly again.
Most pools have sand filters,
whereas hot tubs have cartridge filters.
So what happens is, obviously,
while the filters are
collecting the small particles,
if you don't take them out and rinse them,
your water will start to go cloudy.
So it's basically just
dirt and then obviously
anything that comes off
your body, like dead skin.
Anything can get caught
up in the filter as well.
So you can rinse them down
with your garden hose,
and then you can spray
them with filter cleaner,
which just disinfects any
bacteria that's on them.
And then put them straight
back into the hot tub,
and then they're ready to go again.
On hot tubs you can get a
little floating dispenser,
and it just floats around on the water,
just slowly releasing chlorine or bromine.
There's also a chemical test kit,
and on the left will be to test
for the bromine or chlorine level,
and on the right I am
testing for the pH level.
You're looking for the middle color,
which is around 7.2.
So, with the hot tub, it was looking,
after I'd finished with it,
it was looking brand
new, nice and blue again.
The customer's really happy with it,
and it just looked like a new hot tub
rather than what it did,
like, five hours ago.
That was definitely the worst
hot tub I've ever worked on,
and actually seeing the final product
with nice and blue water in it again,
nice and clear, and
everything working on there,
I was pretty happy with that.
For his last trick,
witness Miles as he takes
this pool from green to clean.
Today, I'm going to show
you a few different pools
and how I clean the bottom of the pool.
Grandma's pool definitely
was the most challenging.
The sludge on the bottom,
it was, like, 6 inches of
sludge across the whole pool.
It looked very abandoned
because obviously it'd
been left for 15 years.
So that was when I
first got into the pool.
Obviously there was a lot,
the water had been drained
down quite a lot there.
But as I stepped in, it was really soft.
Branches may have fell off of
the bushes that were around the pool
and then just sort of,
they could have started
growing bigger as well
while they were in the pool as well.
So we had to shovel it into buckets,
and then someone would
put it in a wheelbarrow
and take it down to the heap
at the end of the garden,
and it just created a
massive pile of just sludge.
I'd say there was probably a ton
or maybe 2 tons of sludge.
So, yeah, draining that down
and scooping all the
sludge out of that one
and just the time it took,
yeah, that was definitely the hardest one.
But we got it there in the end.
Oh, my God. So, recently,
I've been to a job,
and the pool has been left
for, like, eight years,
but the water, weirdly, was clear,
but the algae in there
was really blanket-like,
and there was loads of it,
and I could move it around,
and you could see it looked really weird,
like an underwater sort
of forest of algae.
It was really bad.
And that pool definitely
had to be drained down.
OK, so when I first go to a pool
and I see that it's green,
what I'll do first is
get a pool brush out,
and then I'll brush the whole pool,
all the surfaces, disturbing
all the algae off the surface.
Normally algae will just break up.
Like, you put chemicals
in, you brush the pool,
and it will just break up
into really small particles,
and then you can just Hoover it.
But this type of algae was just really
stringy and just solid together.
Yeah, it was a weird one.
And then, again, there's
sludge on the floor.
We're just brushing the sludge to a pile
and then scooping it out.
That pool had been left just,
gone a couple of days without chlorine,
and because it was indoor,
sort of in a greenhouse type,
so it got really hot in
there when the sun comes out,
and just the algae just attached itself
to the tiles so badly.
It looked like it had been left for years.
People thought they were
actually green tiles
on the steps. And it was
really tough on the tiles.
It needed something quite
aggressive to get it off.
And then what I got was
just some hydrochloric acid,
mixed it with water, and
sprayed it over the tiles,
and it just started
reacting with the algae
by bubbling up.
And then I started brushing it in
to disturb it all off the surface.
Then I got the hose
and started watering it
down, and it all cleaned off.
Come up nice and blue.
And then rinsed it down.
And that literally took, like, 15 minutes.
The woman who owned the pool,
she only called us to come
and open the pool in August.
Had the whole summer just
sitting there doing nothing.
So we took the cover off,
and there was mosquito larvae in the pool,
and there was mosquitoes
flying everywhere.
Literally so bad I had to
run away from the pool.
And she actually didn't
want this pool emptied,
she just wanted to try and get it around
with chemicals and get some chemicals out.
Shock and chlorine granules
were used on this one.
So, when I shock a pool,
that basically kills off
all the algae and all the
contaminants in the pool.
Basically what it does is
combine all the small particles,
and what it relies on is
no movement in the water.
So it's combining all the particles,
and then they become heavy,
and then they just sink to the bottom.
Yeah, after a few days, come back,
and it was like, the
water was crystal clear.
Just all the debris and
everything was just on the bottom.
And I came in and just Hoovered it up,
and it was just crystal clear.
Ready-to-go sort of thing.
So, if you've got an outdoor pool,
you're going to want to maintain it
once a week at least.
Nah, so, I get a lot
of people do say to me,
"Why don't you drain
the pool before winter?"
But what it is, is you've got
to take into consideration
the structure of the pool.
So if you have no water in there,
if there's water in the
ground surrounding the pool,
it can pressurize the walls
and then cause damage.
You have to keep water in the pool.
What you do have to do is check your pool
at least once a month and
add the correct chemicals,
and then when you come
to open it in summer,
it's going to be nice and clear still.
Your allergies will thank you after
47 years of dust is cleaned out of this vent.
Today, I'm going to show you how I clean
47 years of dust out of vents.
As soon as we walked in,
we see the old vents,
the furnace, how old it was.
Before even opening any of the vents up,
I knew how bad it was gonna be.
You know, he said 47 years of dust,
probably over 100 years, to be honest.
If you look at a vent and you see dust
on the actual vent,
that's a clear sign that
the ducts have probably never been cleaned
and they're pretty filthy inside.
We like to start on the
very top of the house
and work our way down.
That tool that we're using,
we call it whiskers.
The whiskers are just made out of rubber.
The end of it's attached
to an air compressor,
and you have air just
coming out through the rod,
out the little whisker things.
[whiskers whirling]
So, what you're looking at right now
is just me pulling chunks of dust out
that have probably been in there
for over 100 years.
There was too much dust
to be putting it in the vacuum,
so I literally went in there with my hands
and grabbed probably,
like, 5 pounds of dust.
Isn't it gnarly?
Like, look at how much dust that is.
It's just so sick, honestly.
This is the back of the dryer,
and you guys can pretty much see
there's an endless amount
of lint coming out.
There's a few reasons why you should get
your dryer vent cleaned.
It's a huge fire hazard,
and your clothes will
dry more efficiently.
It's well worth the money
to just pay to get it cleaned every year.
The vacuum is on throughout
the whole process,
and what we're doing is blowing
all that dust and debris
closer and closer to the vacuum.
This house in particular had 18 vents.
Most of the time,
I think probably 75% of the time,
the houses that we go to
have never been cleaned.
People just don't think about it.
You know, getting your air ducts cleaned
isn't, like, a regular thought
that comes to your head.
The dust you typically
see in your vents is,
most of it is actually human skin cells.
Yeah, it's pretty gnarly.
So, right now we're done,
and everything's pretty much good to go.
You're pretty much going to see
a brand-new home, honestly.
You're going to feel much better.
Your health is going to be better.
I actually got a phone
call after that job,
and they said all their
allergies went away.
It's just a huge health benefit, honestly.
You might not notice the small stuff,
but your body does.
Clogged gutters can wreak havoc on a home,
but The Gutter Guyz can
clear them out with ease.
I'm Broden, and I own a business
in Connecticut called The Gutter Guyz.
Today I'm going to show
you how to clean gutters
with wet and dry debris.
So, when we clean a
gutter with wet debris,
nine times out of 10,
we want to clean it by hand.
The reason why is when it's wet,
it typically is very muddy
and there's a lot of what we call
shingle dust or grit in the gutters,
and it's literally a mud.
And when we blow them when they're wet,
it makes a muddy mess all over the house.
We want to clean them
by hand for that reason.
So, that is a gutter that is completely
jammed with leaves and debris,
and the downspout was completely covered.
When we released the
debris out of the downspout
and got that gutter cleaned,
all of that rainwater
that was in the gutter
just started to flow very heavily
right down the downspout, as it should.
So, oftentimes when we
do a gutter cleaning,
not only do we find leaves,
but we find plants so big
that we actually call them trees,
sometimes, growing right out of a gutter.
We're actually pulling out a big plant,
and you can see the whole root system
come right out with it.
Certain types of trees give off
these little things that come off the tree
and will grow another tree,
and when those land in the gutter,
it's a perfect environment
for that to grow.
It's a classic sign that your gutters
have not been cleaned in years.
It also puts a significant
amount of weight
from the whole root system
growing in the gutter
on the gutter, which in turn
will pull that gutter
off of the fascia board,
which is actually the
board behind the gutter
that the gutter is mounted to.
Wet debris is usually
just saturated with water.
Water will overflow at the gutter
and get into your basement
and create cracks in your foundation.
Once water does find its
way into your basement,
it wreaks havoc.
Here, the water that's flowing
out of the downspout at the bottom
is the end result that we are looking for.
So that water will flow down and out,
as it properly should.
When we see dry debris,
the reason why that debris is dry
is because there has not been any rain
in the past, I would say, week or so.
So when we clean a gutter
that has dry debris,
oftentimes we will use a hand blower
and blow those gutters out,
because it does a really good job
of just getting everything
out of the gutter,
whether it be leaves or
sticks or curly stuff
that comes off in the spring.
Depending on the pitch of the roof,
we will get on that roof,
start our hand blower,
and walk across that roofline
hand-blowing out all of the debris
out of that gutter.
Sometimes the debris is very compact
and it's thick.
That's a classic sign of
maybe a couple of years
that somebody had not had
their gutters cleaned.
We stick to one type of ladder,
and that's an aluminum ladder.
The aluminum ladder does
conduct electricity,
so it's very important we stay
away from power lines
when we are moving aluminum ladders.
We could get severely electrocuted.
It's certainly deadly,
which is why we mark the
power-line areas with flags
before we start a gutter cleaning.
Because you're looking
where you're walking,
so you don't look up
to see the power lines.
So it's very important for us to have
the reminder that power lines are there.
We will often drop a
penny down the downspout
just to know that that
downspout's free and clear,
because we can see and hear it go
all the way through and
back out at the bottom
and we know that we're in good shape.
The best advice I can give a homeowner
is to be proactive, not reactive.
Typically when you're
reactive, it's too late.
Damage has been done,
the water may already be in your basement,
it may already be in your home,
and it's just not a good
way to maintain your house.
Water is seriously
detrimental to your house,
and the main cause of
water is from your gutters.
So if you keep the gutters free and clear
and you do consistent cleaning,
whether it be two or three times per year,
which we recommend,
you will never have any issues
with water in your basement
or ruining your flower beds
or rotting out the fascia
and soffits of your home.
Just stay on top of gutter cleaning.
Step up your spring cleaning with Aj
as he pressure washes years of dirt.
My name's Aj Joyner,
owner of Advanced Pressure Washing, LLC.
So, today we're gonna show you
how we clean the exterior of a client's
dirty home, step by step.
We, in general, we
offer exterior cleaning,
but the main services
in the residential field
are house washing, gutter clean-out,
concrete cleaning.
Those are the main-ticket items
that we solicit to the
residential clients.
The condition of the fence
structurally is great,
but as you can see,
it's covered in mildew and algae.
Wood is very particular
because if you use too much pressure,
you're gonna cause a lot of damage
to the surface.
So to treat it, we just
use moderate pressure.
We make sure always to go with the grain.
This keeps us from
furrowing/damaging the wood.
The driveway is terrible.
Covered in mildew and algae.
The chemicals we normally use is called
sodium hypochlorite 12.5%,
or better known as pool
shock/industrial bleach.
We normally dilute that down to
a 50:50 ratio in our buckets.
This kills the mildew and algae,
that top layer, when we pretreat,
it kills that almost instantly.
This is called a
Whisper Wash Big Guy surface cleaner.
That metal tubing
actually rotates around on a swivel.
That's the item that I use
to actually clean concrete.
From there, we'll actually go around
washing the trim of around the brick
and other areas the surface
cleaner couldn't reach.
And then we will post-treat
with a detergent again
to get any organic stains
that are left behind.
After we do the driveway,
we'll then do the front
patio and sidewalk.
Also sometimes if the client wants,
we'll also do the curves along the drive.
The house is in pretty good condition,
but there was a few spots that we noticed
that were pretty bad
with heavy and thick mildew and algae.
On a house we use roughly about
10% sodium hypochlorite
mixed with about 90% water.
So, the black on the brick
is actually just really
thick mildew and algae.
This is caused by moisture in shade,
allowing for such big
mildew and algae to grow.
When we wash a house's exterior,
we wash the roof, the
outside of the gutters,
the side of the home, the windows,
the doors, anything that is on the side
or attached to the home itself.
So, we're finished.
We finally got the job done.
So, roughly, this job took us
about four and a half hours.
Everything looked amazing.
The client was beyond happy
with the job that we've done.
You can clearly see
everything is transformed
into a new clean state.
My personal suggestion,
instead of trying to do it yourself,
is to always hire a professional,
because you're dealing
with some very strong
and dangerous chemicals,
and it can be termed dangerous
when in the hands of
someone not experienced.
Sleep peacefully as Jon from Super Fresh
takes years off of this mattress' life.
My name is Jon Bristol,
and I'm from Trinidad and Tobago.
I'm the director of Super Fresh,
and today I'm going to show you
how we clean very dirty mattresses
as well as the average dirty ones.
So, a typical process of
cleaning a mattress is
we spray on an enzyme-based cleaner,
and that will break down the dirt
and the body oils
and, you know, the incidents.
And we give that chemical
some time to work.
After that, there's some agitation,
also known as scrubbing,
and in the final stage of the process,
we use the extractor,
and that would spray on a
solution of clean water,
fabric shampoo, and deodorizer
and vacuum at the same time.
So it rinses away everything,
so there isn't any harsh chemicals left
to interfere with anyone's skin
or anything afterwards.
There's going to be a lot
of dust buildup over time.
There's going to be hair.
If there are a lot of kids in your home,
you're going to find urine,
even if the client doesn't know.
Sometimes, you know,
some people eat on their beds and stuff,
so you find crumbs from various foodstuff.
All right. So, I actually had no idea
what to expect when coming to do this job.
And I'm still not entirely
sure what caused it.
It may have been some
flooding in the area,
but I'm not sure.
So that was probably more
than five years for sure.
So, right here, I am spraying on
the enzyme-based cleaner
onto the mattress,
and I'm looking to see the areas
where I may have to apply
another coat as we go along.
What I use right now,
it's a synthetic enzyme.
I could use it for everything,
but there are some stains
that would require additional chemicals
if you really want to get
them removed visually.
But the most important
thing for most clients
is getting the actual thing
that caused the stain out.
So we say there may not be
a visual improvement, but you can be sure
that you're getting all the nasties out.
They're usually just regular buildup,
so just regular dust and dirt
that accumulate over the years.
Some clients don't use
a full three-piece sheet set.
A lot of clients don't have
mattress protectors either.
Using heat is beneficial because
heat acts almost like
a universal catalyst.
So heat would help your
chemicals to work faster,
so it would help the enzyme cleaner
to break down the stuff faster,
and it will also help the fabric shampoo
to latch onto the dirt particles faster.
So it helps make the cleaning
process more efficient.
Unfortunately, there's
no way to know for sure
that you get 100% of it,
but you want to know
that you're picking up
as much as possible.
This mattress was especially dirty,
so it's either, like, a lot of years,
probably more than seven or so,
or a lot of use.
But I don't think it's any one thing,
but just a combination of factors
that leaves it to be that condition.
I found that you could use
a variable-speed polisher
and a scrubbing-brush attachment.
The brush is rotating at about 600 rpm.
We use the softest brush available,
because some fabrics are really delicate.
And we use that to help break down
the larger debris and stuff
on the surface of the fabric.
So it helps break down the
larger pieces of debris,
'cause sometimes they have buildup
that is really, really bad,
and it's actually, like, caked up.
The general process for removing stains
is just to isolate where the stain is,
and I may double-apply the
enzyme-based cleaner to it
or I may spend a little
longer scrubbing it.
[water gushing]
[cleaner buzzing]
I believe for this one the client told us
it was probably about two years,
and it wasn't too bad.
It was just, like, a cream-ish color,
but we know the original color was white,
and so we sprayed it one time
and we did the scrubbing.
I mean, you'll always have the extreme.
Some would be much, much darker brown.
Some would be much more spotty.
But the average person
is just a little cream,
just a little off-white
from where it should be.
For mattresses, you're
usually going to get
those kind of colors,
because even below the surface,
you still have a lot of debris.
Your dead skin cells,
your dirt, and your dust building up.
So even if the top surface
doesn't accurately
represent what is hidden
inside there, you're going to find it
once we do the extraction.
[water gushing]
After a certain amount of years,
your mattress significantly
increases in weight
simply due to the dust
and dead skin cells that collect.
So, one, it's going to
be more uncomfortable.
Two, if you're using it regularly,
some of that is going
to be entering the air.
So you're going to have
a lower-quality air
inside the home. It may attract mites
if there's a lot of moisture around.
Just overall it's not going to be
the best way of well-being.
For people that are asthmatic,
the buildup of dust could be a problem.
For people with sensitive skin,
any buildup on your mattress over time
could pose a threat in the future
in terms of having flare-ups.
If you're taking only
preventative measures,
I don't think you should need to service
more than, like, once a year.
Get it cleaned and then
get a mattress protector,
because you can always wash that
every fortnight or every month,
and you're in a much better position
than paying me. And I don't mind,
but you're in a much better position
for your own well-being.
Jay from Cleannex takes
us behind the scenes
of reviving a restaurant's
greasy exhaust system.
My name is Jay Lopez,
and I'm the owner of Cleannex.
Today, I'm gonna be walking you through
how we clean a kitchen exhaust system
in a restaurant.
The purpose of a kitchen exhaust system
is to extract the fumes from a kitchen
in a commercial setting.
In order to remove grease,
you have to understand grease.
What holds the oil together is the fat,
and once the first layer is up,
it becomes a magnet,
and it attracts more and more and more.
Everything is cleaned from top to bottom,
and you would start
cleaning the fan first.
We're using a high-end degreaser
with a little added ingredient,
potassium hydroxide and sodium hydroxide.
Those two chemicals
combined create miracles
in destroying the fat and the grease.
In our case, we time it
somewhere between 10 to 15 minutes.
Once we see that the
grease starts to melt,
at that point, we know
we need to apply hot water and remove it,
because anything longer at that point
is going to start to destroy the metal.
Once the fan has been cleaned,
the next step would be the duct.
That's the part that
connects the fan to the hood.
This level is considered extreme.
That was a fire waiting to happen.
I would say this is about
a year worth of grease.
It all depends on the volume of cooking.
If this is moderate cooking,
this is about a year's worth of grease.
That's a lot.
The duct is cleaned in
a few different steps.
During this process,
we use a tool made by Guardian.
This tool is known as the
EZ Magnetic Duct Scraper.
It has magnets set into the tool
and a razor blade on each side.
Once it's clenched to the duct,
it is manually moved forward and backwards
until the grease is removed.
This forward-and-backward method
assures that the grease buildup
will be removed from both sides.
It will go from the yellow color
all the way into the black.
When it's in the black level,
that's an extreme level.
That means that the system
has not been properly maintained.
In these types of designs,
we'll use duct spinners and duct brushes.
Duct spinner is designed to self-rotate
within a protective cage
and spray water at high speed,
which dislodges buildup
from the metal duct.
We use a combination
of a foaming agent and a degreaser.
The foam is used as a delivering agent,
and that allows the
degreaser to stay in contact
with the grease for a longer period.
If foam was not used,
the degreaser would drip off the grease.
The next step would be
the hood and the filters.
See, the filters are your
first line of defense.
What the filters is doing
is holding back heat
and is holding back most of that grease.
When the filters no
longer can hold the grease
and once that grease starts
getting heat and melting,
you have the potential of that grease
dropping into your food.
And at that point, it's a health issue.
I've seen restaurants been shut down
by the health department
for not cleaning their hood.
I've seen restaurants been shut down
by the fire marshal
for not maintaining their hoods.
We take precaution
in protecting the area from contamination.
We use two layers of plastic sheeting
in order to protect the appliances
from coming in contact with any chemical.
The second layer of plastic sheeting
is wrapped around the hood,
and then a funnel is created.
The funnel is used to
drain the chemical grease
and water into the plastic containers.
The plastic sheeting also serves
as a protective barrier
in preventing the chemical from
coming in contact with
the food-preparation area.
Once we're completed
and the plastic sheeting is removed,
we'll conduct a freshwater wipe down
and recommend to the client
that they do the same
prior to preparing any food.
According to NFPA 96,
which is the agency that
regulates this industry,
the frequency of cleanings
depends on the style of
cooking you're conducting
and the frequency of cooking.
For example, if you cook with solid fuel,
solid fuel is basically
cooking with charcoal.
Those are 30-day mandatory cleanings,
because they produce a lot more grease,
and the embers that
come from the solid fuel
can ignite the grease.
If you're an occasional cooking facility,
those would be a year.